les chantiers se multiplient à montigny
le bretonneux le forum des arts charles
aznavour est actuellement l'un des plus
gros chantiers de montigny construit sur
l'ancien collège henri bergson
l'établissement qui veut recentrer une
grosse partie de l'activité culturelle
de la ville ouvrira en septembre
prochain
l'entrée principale présente à son parti
sur la zone rez de chaussée les
activités dédiées au théâtre notamment
avec quatre ateliers d'à peu près 100
mètres carrés chacun et puis donc toute
une partie administrative et cette
ouverture que vous verrez tout à l'heure
sur l'auditorium
le forum sera composé de deux étages au
premier les activités de musique où il
accueillera le conservatoire de montigny
et au second les activités de danse avec
trois studios de plus de 150 mètres
carrés chacun
c'est un espace culturel que nous avons
voulu au coeur d'un projet qui s'intègre
en fin de compte dans l'environnement du
quartier
voilà puisqu'à côté en bas côté de
l'équipement public
nous allons avoir une vaste esplanade
minérale et arboré à côté un parking
vélo de 69 places et un parking paysager
qui jouxtera l'air de jeu réaménagé pour
un coût de 18,5 millions d'euros autres
chantiers en cours le pôle petite
enfance situé à la place de l'ancien
groupe scolaire albert samain
l'établissement comprendra une nouvelle
crèche de 36 berceaux et un relais
d'assistantes maternelles à laitages la
petite enfance à montils libre autobus
toujours été quelque chose de très
important parce qu'on a toujours eu une
offre de qualité pour pouvoir répondre
en fin de compte aux besoins des
familles il faut savoir que ça
représente 450 berceau sur la ville et
c'est une des meilleures offres
aujourd'hui qui assure les yvelines ce
projet favorisera la mise en relation
entre les familles et les professionnels
du secteur
il coûtera 5,3 millions d'euros et sera
financé à 50% par la mairie et à 50% par
les programmes immobiliers puisque 21
maisons de ville et 15 logements sociaux
vont être construits l'ouverture est
également prévue pour la rentrée est
l'établissement qui est déjà ouvert
depuis plus d'une semaine est un projet
vieux de dix ans la maison de santé
pluriprofessionnelle universitaire situé
dans les locaux rénovés de l'ancienne
école jacques prévert cette structure
regroupe 24 praticiens médecins
diététiciens psychologues ou encore
kinésithérapeute
nos médecins de ville aujourd'hui on
sont installés depuis assez longtemps
déjà sur montigny et donc il fallait
penser à l'avenir en termes d'offre de
soins sur la ville cette maison de santé
accueillera aussi des jeunes doctorants
qui viennent de l'université